a big day today for sunrise hospital and
medical center
as they have partnered with the u.s
department of health and human services
to operate get this a monocolon antibody
infusion clinic to treat covet 19
patients right here in las vegas
it's being the third federally supported
infusion clinic
in the country eight news now reporter
madison kimbrough joins us live from
from sunrise hospital to tell us more
about this significant treatment
yes the opening took place this morning
in the clinic is already treating
several several covet 19 patients as we
speak now take a look at the shots that
we took this morning
the goal is to treat these patients who
are at high risk of being hospitalized
due to the virus
for clarification monoclonal antibodies
are laboratory made proteins
that resemble the immune system's
ability to fight off harmful viruses
like
covid19 the hope is that through the
clinic patients with coven 19 will be
able to get treated without having to
enter the hospital doors
saving not only that person's life but
also freeing up space
within the hospital to prevent
overcrowding
standalone clinic that we have eight
treatment chairs eight infusion chairs
for patients will be able to care for 32
patients per day
and those patients need to be referred
from other emergency rooms physician
offices
urgent care centers
now at sunrise hospital they are
currently at an all-time high with
covet positive patients and they expect
those numbers to increase due to the
holiday season
now it should be noted that this clinic
is temporary
only to help with the overcrowding
that's happening inside of the hospital
so this isn't a clinic that's going to
stay up for months and months at a time
only temporarily while the hospital is
able
to provide enough bedding all right
sending it back to you